when humanity has
crumbled and fallen into the sea you
know when earthquakes and volcanoes
ravage our planet
scholars will look back and remember the
frenemies podcast
as the only lasting vestige of humanity
that matters
today i bring you that show me ethan
klein
and my co-host trisha paytas we're here
we are here i'm so excited i'm like
jittery i'm so excited for jake this is
like
christmas right now oh you're ready to
go in i'm
so ready to go it i've been censored by
tick tock this past week where people
are like ooh
she got oh she's deleting stuff i have
gotten stuff taken down from my tick
tock tick tock is censoring me
and even youtube i get scared of
censoring me but because you guys have
like connects to youtube i'm like oh i
can go in on this podcast well you
youtube is really lenient on on [ __ ]
talk or however you want to call it yeah
because there
because youtube understands we're all
public figures
youtube is very pro free speech they
really only step in if it's like
way over the line like with leafy he
made like
you know what over 10 videos in the
course of two weeks about one person
and they erased his channel who was it
who was he talking about uh this girl
pokemane
what random beef right there yeah no it
was totally random
but like but but other than that that's
the only time i've ever seen them really
step in bel delphine just got deleted
i know [ __ ] pour one out for a homie
but that you have cadets can't you help
her or is it just like gone
well the thing with belle is that i
think she's in
she's she's beyond what i can help
really wait why what you do well her
videos are i mean i don't think she
should have been banned but
her videos are super suggested i mean
she was always pushing the line of
of oh really i'm surprised that they
just banned her though and didn't give
her any warnings or anything because
she's not a bad actor she just shows
some tits and ass and we love that
she actually showed him no uh
she would she well she was in like a
really thin thong where you could
basically see
like everything that's why they have
only fans that's what i started doing
i'm like oh to my only fans then you can
charge you know
promote on your youtube and then go i
mean i get it i have a feeling that
there's been a lot of blow back and i'm
hoping that she'll get her channel back
but um
but the whole sexual thing they're very
careful about so that that's kind of i
don't really deal with that because i
just talk [ __ ] so i'm good at like
navigating the [ __ ] talking part of
youtube
not so much the showing my vagina part
of youtube yeah it's it's a difficult
one to navigate yeah
it's different because i do that
sometimes too but you gotta okay watch
it
so today's episode you're excited
because
i i was trisha went into an absolute
[ __ ] war
over the past week and i mean it was
crazy to watch
i was like drama getting 2.0 electrician
versus the whole [ __ ]
internet i love that that's the title
because i see trisha versus amelia's
tricks for status and like all these
people think just me versus everybody
it is kind of no that's what it feels
like because all these tech talkers are
popping right now so everyone was all
the tick talkers started piling on this
trend
and so but in reality like i watched
wendy williams this morning came for
charlie did you see that her face was
crying
yeah she's like she has big crying okay
hold that up baby like i don't know if
it's
on it was on this morning wendy williams
after charlie
this morning she said poor parenting
fake crying
what yeah i'm sorry but i have i think
wendy
will i call her wendy because she farted
that one time so i
love wendy she's windy because she
passes on tv
i think she's a i think she's a horrible
human being oh you think she's horrible
why well because she like is
she's first of all so
vain and empty and the [ __ ] she talks
about and obsesses over is just so
vapid and disgusting but that's not it
she's done [ __ ] like you know when she
outed
was it method man's wife for having
cancer
um and i mean [ __ ] like that is like
unforgivably horrible that yeah but like
when people are i hate the whole oh like
she's obsessed with talking about people
it's like that's her job too
you know it's not it's not that she
talks i mean you know there's plenty
people that do that it's the way she
does it is like
i just don't like it i think that's why
people like her a lot of that she's
polarizing like people like hate her or
love her for that reason
well as long as you call her wendy i'll
be happy
i'm a fan of wendy do you believe she
ripped ass onto on on tv or no
i didn't see that what yeah are you like
obsessed with that
well yeah because she ripped ass
hardcore and then she went on a whole
tour trying to explain it like being
like i didn't fart
it was someone backstage but she clearly
did i'm gonna manifest me taking over
her spot when she retires oh
i would like that yeah i would watch i
think people would get down with that
i think that's my that's my calling
that's my direction did you see that
okay yeah no i know you were on howard
it's all there no this week
oh yeah i was listening to it and i was
like she was talking about mukbang so i
was like
that's tricia yeah okay so here she is
ripping ass on live tv so you tell me
what she and look how she's slumped over
like she's obviously trying to pass
she's trying to pass the silent one this
i mean you'll turn it up a little bit
what that was edited who's this [ __ ]
get the
i hate when people do that speculation
is it a big deal someone farts on live
tv
it's kind of funny especially when they
go on a tour trying to deny it
what do you mean a tour like she
literally did like episodes and all the
shipping like i did not
like bill clinton was like i did not i
did not fart on television
yeah i'm kind of on bill clinton's side
actually i read his book this weekend
it's old book but i like it
i mean i'm on his side and monica when
she's booked too we should have monica
lewinsky on this podcast i wish you'd do
it
monokalinsky we already talked we
already have her uh lined up
she's lined up i'm like an expert i'm
going to climb to read her book this
weekend
why are we talking about this boring
crap dude we have like so much good
stuff to talk about
uh before we get into that
before we get into that teddyfresh.com
black friday sale
this hoodie that i'm wearing you can get
for fifty percent off
at teddyfresh.com black friday sale
onlytrish.com free
this weekend through september
[Laughter]
dueling uh sponsors yeah teddyfresh.com
black friday here you plug your only fan
so we'll talk okay
teddy fresh.com you can get this hoodie
for 50
off only this month because it's black
friday it's more
all right all right all right i have
merch coming out next week so i'm going
to promote that and can you please put
that link
i don't care about now but put that link
in the description because i'll only
link your stuff in the description you
tell me what do you want me to link only
i can't link to your only fans no no i
know i'm not saying that i'm
talking about what the [ __ ] i have a
little thing dropping next week
it's a surprise it's not even the merch
it's like something that goes with it
anyways
okay so so it started with uh
uh what's her name uh charlie dimigo
who they she first of all you weren't
the first person to call her out but
let's just let's just give context
um she had a dinner
can i just say for the record literally
don't care
about this girl at all like i don't have
any beef towards her i never cared
either way
i just thought that this was trending on
my for you page and everyone was
reacting and getting views i was like
i'll just do a reaction like
couldn't care less like if she succeeds
or not like i hope she does
let's watch this clip let's watch this
clip
this is your reaction to the video that
a lot of people are reacting to
[Music]
classic dixie do you have any dino
i threw up that was not good it's a very
dramatic scene
no yeah christian almost puke you have a
child
what do you like
because imagine if i hit a hundred mill
a year after hitting a mill
was the 95 not enough for you well i was
just like saying like
even okay so there's a couple things
that happen in this clip
so she they're spitting out food the
chef made and then she goes on to
complain that she only got 95 million
and not a hundred million to which her
best friend they keep calling each other
called her out right there and be like
why 95 million was not like he's the one
that called it out like to me i wouldn't
have said anything but when james was
like oh the shade
like okay he calls her out from the
beginning which there's a conspiracy
there on his own but i do think he was
trying to set her up in a way because i
was like
i'll explain that i want to set this up
okay with
as much clarity as possible first of all
he he makes a comment in that clip
saying if you eat it it
gives you good luck and prosperity which
indicates that what he's serving her
is gross and it's meant to be like a
challenge
as i understand it she has this okay so
but then she her spitting it out
isn't her being rude to the chef he knew
that he was grossing her out
what do you mean he she has a phobia for
snails and he cooks
how do you know i watched a video and
she says i don't like snails and he
cooks nails trying to gross me out
okay sure i get it like i mean here's
the thing overall the thing is also
silly anyways but it was a viral video
that people like and to be honest
if you watch the whole dinner they're
extremely disrespectful to their parents
like
so let's pull up the video i mean it's
long it's like 16 minutes it's a whole
different way i'm not watching that so
which is fine go to
we always shot them out but duffer
noodles did a whole like highlights of
like how their career ended basically
going through the whole dinner i mean
they were consistently just brats to
their hair
you know okay that's not what they're
being criticized for yeah i think it is
just bratty behavior that's exactly
that's what i was
like oh man they're like a little like a
little snotty she's 19. she's not a
child like the other girl 16.
it's like do you really need to like
puke and be so dramatic if you are being
funny
that's on her team for giving her bad
publicity like you really want to make
these are brand friendly like teenagers
and you really want to make them look
entitled and spoiled when we're going
through like a pandemic and [ __ ] it's
like
but that was bad marketing on their part
yeah they're not even nicole smith where
it's like
oh it's cool to be disgusting or me you
know like that's like trashy behavior i
would do they're going to put someone
who has a duncan brand deal in this
position
yeah maybe they missed the mark a little
bit but like the amount of [ __ ] they
were getting i thought was way over the
top
but that's the internet okay okay okay
but you agree you agree of course
okay good my reactions when i watched
but you didn't you weren't the you
weren't the first one i saw tons of
people before i saw yours
and my initial reaction was like what
though who the why are you giving this
poor girl such a hard time
i mean it was like shitty behavior i
totally agree with that and they're on
such a pedestal they're the most famous
person on tick tock i don't think you're
at pets so people [ __ ] on them all the
time
well now because their true colors are
showing don't worry come on it's not a
true color thing she's just a girl who
dances nobody said she's not saying no
not sure
an angel she's a girl who dances and got
absurdly famous on tick tock nobody said
that she's [ __ ] you know
saint john the divine she's just a girl
no but that's
she's not just a girl she's the most
famous person on the internet i know but
this exception
but this expectation for her to be
absolutely perfect she's a 16 year old
girl no one expects it but
she got she called me out for calling
her boring i'm like girl not everyone's
gonna get what you're doing like you are
boring you don't dance well like i'm not
trying to be a hater i'm allowed to have
an opinion when you have 100 million
followers brand deals with duncan all
this money good for you
don't expect people to not like critique
your actions that's that's the limelight
she's not famous for her talent she's
famous for being a personality and
people are going to critique her that's
why she's famous for
personality you know a personality is
what i'm saying it's kind of i think
she's famous for this by the way can i
ask
i've been i've been spending a lot of
time on tick tock this dance is so dumb
and i don't get it they go
they just step to the side oh i like
that one it goes they go
you light me up in size
it's so dumb they all do it yeah can we
do that i'll probably
take talk today i wanted to do one where
i just step
to the side the whole time i think that
dance is tiny i think that's why tic tac
is popular and they're popular they do
very basic dances
okay well anyway she got a bunch of [ __ ]
and i just also say like
i don't believe it like like no one can
get canceled clearly i'm proof of that
no one can get cancel i want no one's
trying to cancel her check i'm getting
death threats it's like these are the
nine-year-olds that leave the little
fairies like hang yourself if you're
getting actual death threats don't
go on instagram live like call the cops
it's like little it's this little it's
just
okay well she's a 16 year old girl it's
hard listen it's hard for anybody to
process this she's
still new to like internet fame let's be
honest she's not been around as long as
me and you
right through them and she's only 16
years old so
it's very stressful and i'm sure that
she feels really bad so
you know i understand why she'd be like
hey trisha [ __ ] you because
what did i do i just reacted with
everyone else how come i got singled out
well let's see what you said okay
let's let's open it up i don't even know
what i said i'm like where did i
start reaction to this video of the
demilios and james charles having dinner
with a chef and i've seen lots of
comments from
dixie saying like just kind of being
really competitive and bratty towards
people
who had criticisms of the girls there's
a chef making them food they're being
really disrespectful just spitting out
the food
and okay so again this was the narrative
i saw but it's taking out all the
context that it was meant to be a gag
they were meant to be gross yeah they're
saying that now okay that's the gig then
why do they edit it like that like make
it the gag of like a reality like the
osborne's like hey you're gonna have
this really great well bad editing you
can blame a bad editing but the way she
should the way she okay whatever they're
young but i do
think since they are role models on such
a big platform they should be called out
when
they need to be humbled a little because
you see this happen all the time
can i tell you also the the way she was
reacting to the comments was actually
like my issue the oldest one the 19 year
old
was like being so like rude to people
back like that's my big thing is like
when people are like oh like you guys
are being rude and she was just
basically like telling people to like
i don't know the exact i don't want to
like misquote or something like that but
basically telling people like you're the
problem and like just being snotty back
it's like
dude like first of all first of all i
think rule number one when you're this
famous and you're brand friendly and all
this like
fighting back beneath you is so not the
move i agree but they're just
i think yeah i agree with you but
they're just they're they're
dude you know it takes it takes a lot of
time on the internet and a lot of
maturity which they don't have yet the
problem number one is that james charles
says he's their mentor i mean that's
number one that nick's him
from your life he's their mentor
predatory behavior i'm the mentor for
charlie she doesn't need me and i don't
need her i'm like james you were failing
miserably before you got charlie
oh you know what he's doing though he's
definitely been like i'm her mentor
which means that i can use her to
promote anything i make any time i want
oh yeah
i'm keeping her real close well yes she
was the one in that teddy fresh hoodie
that he was promoting
she was all up in that yeah she was like
the main one and so of course people are
on
his side because of charlie that's how
his his youtube career came back
and that's cool but like you're still 21
hanging out the 16 year old don't say
like you don't need each other you need
okay hold on you're getting ahead of
yourself there's a lot
to cover let's finish this really famous
a lot of followers okay
one more thing oh my god okay go ahead
one more thing is like
this was like just a trend that people
were getting views on so i was like okay
i'm gonna
yeah i understand that this is not
something that i was like this is my
issue and i'm gonna like take it
but you did make like a billion videos
no prior to her calling me out i made
these two the two the reaction one the
duet
that's the only two i made prior and now
that's why i was like shook when she
called me i was like what the
[ __ ] like it was so weird did your video
get a lot of views i got 10 million but
like
a lot so she probably saw yours and i
was like [ __ ] trisha who the [ __ ] is she
to call me out
which is kind of fair right no no it's
like hey [ __ ] you
who the [ __ ] are you to call me off the
best part though i've been trash she's
19 at 19 i was sucking dick on santa
monica boulevard for five dollars she's
living a cushy life with her parents
five bucks really yeah you're really
gonna compare
if you want to compare you to me that's
fine but like i'm trash i've been trash
since day one on the internet these
people are like
famous brand friendly happy kids i was
always a miserable hold on only five
bucks
yeah you didn't i feel like you could
you could
i was on heavy drugs when i was 19.
you're just like [ __ ] give me the
oh my god i don't even know what's the
most you've charged for a [ __ ]
five dollars because i never really
charged yeah you know like escorting was
different but
yeah i was like you know at that age i
was literally
you're just like whatever
maybe if you've got the teeth out of the
way you could be charging 10 15 bucks
you'd be rich i try to learn like
covering my teeth with my lips since i
can't i just can't do it sorry
right here is that how you wanted to
blow job like that i don't know i'm just
covering my hair
here trisha this is how it's done and
then like the lips i don't know a tongue
around it i have no idea
okay we appreciate the effort it's fine
they think they're entitled to take it
with tease without teeth the [ __ ]
and whatever you got well 95 million
followers they complain that they have a
personal chef
and it's just unbecoming and i don't
think it's something to be embarrassed
about because they are young girls but
to
be catty and bratty in the comments when
people are just like hey we're kind of
like this isn't cool behavior
it's just trying to help them learn and
ultimately not get canceled because this
kind of attitude
it won't get you far i mean it was just
about how they were replying to fans
that's what i said there it's like how
how she was responding to people giving
them criticism she was being such like a
little [ __ ] about it i was like
we're all like be humble they're saying
this attitude from you
i actually do agree in that but
i agree in that what you're saying is
right if they i think if they would have
just ignored by the way
her sub's already going up she's like
she's like undefeated she's ready she's
already crossed 100 billion
100 of course yeah she was like losing
followers from that so
my this is my theory so then james her
mentor because
she don't give a [ __ ] about me like you
don't even mean like you have 100
million i feel like she was her feeling
for her
no i do that's what she said no this was
so perfect because then when she started
crying
she calls me out the number i'm more
hated than probably anyone on the
internet
and yeah i get like my glimpse of people
being like yes trish yes trish and it's
only my time that i get canceled again
or whatever
so it's an easy scapegoat because then
james charles piled on that same day
so it's obviously a deflection which hey
i'm all about deflection when shane was
going through his [ __ ] i'm like yeah he
did some
shitty [ __ ] but let's talk about david
dobrik being making pedophile jokes
let's talk about
you have to like you know that's what
you do when you like go down for your
like ride or die so obviously she's
getting canceled
for something so stupid but she's losing
followers like you know what let's go
for trish because she's a real easy
target for people to say hey
and guess what people that hate me but
not that people love me again this
morning so
yeah it's kind of funny now the comments
this morning on my tic tacs like we love
you
no but but no it's so funny because
everyone
it started with everybody dog piling on
her and then you joined the crowd
and then they're like [ __ ] trisha and
then i was like yeah [ __ ] trisha
and then now she's gaining subs and
everyone's over and i was like charles
no but then okay well we're we are
getting ahead but then dixie dance to
the n-word and then oh yeah we're
getting into that
james it was it's it's been a roller
coaster ride i just imagine like a mob
with
with torches and pitchforks running back
and forth
ah you know that's exactly how it was
it's so fun the great thing about
everyone keep saying i'm like old and
should be on tick tock or like
like talking about this the great thing
about being old is like really just not
caring like i
when i was younger no but like you know
i'm older than you by a lot
okay by like three years but you know
what i'm saying like when i was younger
and an influencer didn't like me like
tyler glee and grace it was like oh
[ __ ] those are like my peers but now
they're like teenagers so i couldn't
give like i couldn't
care less if they like me or not and
it's so fun to watch now but don't you
think it's a bit
so uh the criticism against you which i
kind of agree with
it's a bit much to be even like you know
[ __ ] on a six-year-old girl
because it's a trend and i'm just like
oh this is the most popular girl and
thing i'm not [ __ ] on her i
literally was like
making faces i was like oh and then i
was saying hey be humble in your world
it's true that she is you know the
biggest person person on tick tock so
that's a big target
she can make millions of dollars off
social media but then when people have
reactions it's like
how dare you she's 16. it's like all
right so here's her sister
okay can i just say also for the record
charlie the 16 year old is really the
victim in this she has her racist leech
of a sister
she has james charles mentoring her she
has her parents who aren't saying [ __ ]
like she really is the victim in all
this so charlie like my
my condolences yeah that's not really
apology but i don't think she would take
that as apology but okay
i wasn't apologizing i'm sending her my
condolences condolences right yeah
hold on one second know the full story
so my family and i've been working with
chef aaron may for a couple months now
actually you're the only person that
talks faster than her i drive faster
than all of them
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm trisha they
have ultimate fast talking
all the comments will be a 32 year old
trying to compete with the 19 year old
you like you know those old western
shootouts with the fastest gun
you got to meet her at high noon be like
i was on that show guinness world
records for the most words per minute
yeah yeah i was on truth did you break
the record
i didn't because i didn't count a lot of
the words because i had to do hamlet
soliloquy to be or not to be
and that's hard yeah right that's what i
thought the the words and they were
already hard but um
they didn't count but i was on all the
problems now do you remember the
soliloquy i don't remember i did at the
time this was like
again 10 years ago but i was on the
press tour with him like going on good
morning america what if we get you a
guinness world record could do
do you think you could break the record
now are you out of shape ptsd from that
because i i think
because i do when i get nervous i like
trip over my words
and like even like singing like i feel
like i'm not the worst singer but when i
audition i like
i'm the worst like i'm awful like when i
sing in front of people so i think
that's like a stage fright or something
or
what if we hide him in the wall and then
we secretly
he comes he we could dre we could like
paint him so he melts into the wall
and then we'll step forward and be like
time you know i would love to
redo it i think i could maybe do i think
i have contacts there
really yeah okay well i think i've seen
them in my email that'd be amazing it's
something i always wanted because people
thought i had the world record because
on the show okay dixie we're coming for
you officially
for our channel and working on content
for his channel and made an amazing
friendship
and before i even get into anything i'm
so grateful for every single person that
follows me every single person i care
about every single person i work with
no one cares about you they say that
about charlie like this girl is like
making it about herself but no one cares
they never
said you were ungrateful you're a little
sister i'm a single person who works
with me because i'm just so grateful of
all the opportunities i've had
so i would never in any way want to be
taken as disrespectful
especially from an out of context 15
second clip
so basically my team knows i throw up a
lot i can throw up at the smell the
thought or the taste of anything
i think that's called bulimia i mean no
i mean
what am i supposed to think when a young
girl goes yeah i throw up
all the time it's like right that is
concerning again for parenting a doctor
yeah i throw up all the time
like from everything i throw up every
day after
every meal helping her this is when
thirty some things are beneficial to
step in right now because no one else is
she just said she throws up while it
dies i'm just
i don't know i'm not diagnosing her with
bulimia trisha but it's mean i mean
that's a warning sign
it is kind of concerning right she's
like i throw up when i smell carrots i
throw up when i smell uh
tomatoes it's like whoa huh thing so
when they saw the snails they were like
oh let's
get her and see if we can get a reaction
out of her
you're just completely lost that's funny
because you reacted to this video
no i stitch it because it was a viral
video so i was stitching it i got the
first five seconds the stitch is the
first five seconds i didn't see the
whole thing
but honestly like this is damage control
this is what people say after that's
like when i say well
listen listen to what she has to say
because i found it persuasive
you see she's holding a snail shell
she's like what the [ __ ] is this
right she's like you all know i'm
bulimic jesus
we don't know that allegedly trigger
warning so basically that's
legitly trigger warning sorry in advance
the original video is my team and chef
aaron may trying to convince me to try
snail knowing that i would have a
reaction
i love chef and i would never disrespect
him in any way and maybe don't judge
someone's personality over a 15 second
hey guys if you are here to comment okay
so there you go i thought i was like oh
she did he tried to duper into eating a
snail
it's convincing right the whole snail
thing is just so
not important to like the bigger picture
of all this it is because
everybody and you are like these girls
are so ungrateful and they're so
disrespectful to the chef because
they're gagging and spitting out food
but the whole point of the bit was that
he was trying to gross them out
that wasn't the whole point made clear
that was like their damage control was
like you guys everyone knew i was
that's like me being like you guys
everyone knows i'm just dumb [ __ ] so
that's why we talk about hitler and it's
like a joke it's like funny it's like
the thing it's the running bit that i'm
an ignorant person like
no you that's your damage control after
you get called out for [ __ ]
that wasn't the context it wasn't like a
segment in the show james was talking to
charlie and he's like what's so funny
what's happening
she's like going off camera like what is
this what is this it wasn't yeah because
it wasn't a joke like it wasn't a setup
punch line like here well they were
trying to
okay whatever they're trying to surprise
her that's my take but here's that
here's how you responded to the video
you didn't even watch cause i throw up a
lot i could throw up at the smell the
thought or the taste of anything
okay so this is coming as constructive
criticism and not hate whatsoever
um this was not an apology girl this is
not a sincere apology you're making
excuses even watch the whole video
here's pr101 just apologize like if
people are angry at you and you're at
that level
and you have all these fans like
everyone hates me i never i don't have
to apologize i don't want to but i do
but like at that level just apologize
well you're right you're actually
that is that's the way to do it like
replying to people and i'm like what
does this girl do she just she
look she's too young because it's always
like you're always too young
it is dude when i was 19 i was a [ __ ]
idiot trust me
i was getting candles shopped at my ass
when i was 19. yeah i understand that's
not a mark of maturity necessarily but i
was older but you already
picked up my ass then she's old enough
to know this [ __ ]
it's just like the racist thing she
danced to an n-word if you're old enough
to get a candle up your ass yeah you're
old enough to know
not to i don't i don't think a candle up
your ass necessarily indicates the level
of maturity not that it doesn't but i'm
not the level of maturity but legally
i was able to take that you were able to
take that candle
what was it a girthy candle or like a
think candle oh no it was like the
candlestick like holder like it was like
oh
[ __ ] yeah my [ __ ] got ripped honestly
i can't have anal sex anymore i had to
get stitched up it was really bad
i didn't do that i'm not telling was it
a famous person
no no how much do you get paid for that
oh only like a couple thousand i think
oh a couple well that's better than five
bucks true
were they trying to hurt you was that
why yeah probably i was on drugs i think
he did have like a
oh my goodness trisha oh yeah so it was
pretty girthy
he got like him anyways like what
happened to the guy
you don't have to say who he is what
happened to him uh he got called out
like later on for
so some g he met some justice he didn't
meet some dustin that's good
who was it i can't tell you
all right gotta get some sidetrack one
day and just like dude
you have to because you told me nbas
don't really count right no indians are
[ __ ] so i guess if someone stuck a
candle up my
ass without my consent i guess i could
exactly he's committing a crime against
you he can't
he he can't make you consent against
concealing
what's potentially a sexual assault even
if i was a hooker and i was like i'm
down with whatever
you can still rape a hooker of course
but i was like oh i'm down for anything
yes because that is consent i'm saying
i'm down for anything i guess right but
that doesn't mean that he can
commit an illegal act on you it's like
hey i'm down for everything okay just
saw your arm off
you know what i mean that's still a
crime yeah there's when you say i'm down
for anything there's a reasonable
expectation that it doesn't include
killing you right well i don't think it
was gonna kill me but that's what i mean
there's there's limits to what you're
saying here sure
right wrong pipe is this your girdiness
coming out again
no it just went down the wrong part
write that book for real i'll be number
one best seller
because there's so much juice in there
black let's go
and you are 19 so you're a legal adult
charlie is a minor so it's a little
different
but she is saying in this clip that her
team knows that she'll puke
at anything at the smell of anything if
that's the case
why set her up in this situation with a
professional chef in a home
getting a private meal cooked are they
setting up her up for a sabotage
do they want to make her look bratty do
they want to make canada was this all a
pr
stunt just get more i think they're just
pranking her it's not that
it's not that complicated but also this
is just like this is a viral thing
talking about and i'm like what do you
guys think in the comments below
let me know like i'm not like accusing
her of anything to be honest it's the
best pr stunt like if it was because
they did a picture with the chef like a
couple days ago or whatever so to be
honest i think it was to get like a
bunch of people talking about them or
whatever
i don't think it was by design i think
they were trying to prank her and then
they didn't anticipate the reaction no
it's not a prank it's like a series
where they have like a famous person
over for dinner
even my but the best part is when they
thought they were getting like a
celebrity have dinner with them
and james charles walks in and their
faces are like oh who knows
my paper is so disappointing that's
awesome oh is that why he was there
yeah because it's a series like dinner
with the can i be honest do you think
they'd let me have dinner with them on
the next episode
i don't think so i don't think so
i'll go on it yeah i think i think you
burned that bridge
you think mike malzak from impulsive was
like
don't burn bridges you never know who
you have to swim by on the way down or
something like that
like an idiot why is he so cheesy i was
like you know what like i love burning
bridges like let the [ __ ] fires light
the way
better get the floor oh no wait that's
not it let the bodies through the floor
what's the
whatever words to her because if they
were going for comedic effect simple
lifestyle why not feed her fear factor
style stuff like
cow tongue or pig's heart or stuff they
used to feed them and charlie's saying
let's have dino nuggets instead with a
pronounced chef in a private setting
suspicious get a new team girl what'd
you say get a new team yeah cause they
kept saying my team set it up and stuff
like that like
get a new team because you look like
they thought it would be funny they
thought it would be funny and it just
it what i mean you know and then and
then they missed the mark but
yeah missed the mark for sure i think
they'd all so they should just say that
like hey we missed the mark we're sorry
it was toned up
whatever okay so now this is when they
go to war with you
and it starts with charlie uh making
this video saying trisha is very mean
she's a [ __ ] she said she said she's
like trisha is a
[ __ ] she didn't say that she said i was
rude she was a [ __ ]
no it would be funny though she did it
i'd be like hell yeah i'd be like hell
yeah she's a [ __ ]
i am sometimes yeah definitely for sure
all right here we go here's charlie
i'm just going to say trisha paytas like
this is not i'm sorry
just you have been completely rude
to me multiple times saying i'm
she doesn't have a personality she can't
dance she's basic like you have your own
problems please stop worrying about mine
yes um and that's all i have to say on
that quite honestly i
just like please stop talking about me i
have to say there was an hour-long
episode about her
i have to say well it's a recap it's a
recap and it is it is outdated
come on we have to we have to archive
this this is internet lore
yeah this is this is like i have to say
you said the same thing to keemstar
what did i say you said please stop
talking to me and you're like yeah yeah
leave me alone i thought about gabby
hannah too
keep my name out of your mouth but
that's what she's doing to you she's
saying please leave me the [ __ ] alone
no different because i texted keemstar
after he kept coming for me and can you
just like stop
if she privately at me and said hey
trish like you're really affecting my
mental health can you stop a thousand
percent
but she's like keep my name out of your
mouth which is what james charles kylie
jenner it's like
like people can talk about you and also
can i just say they are boring they have
a podcast that's 20 minutes long each
week it's like really
she's a 16 year old girl what the [ __ ]
does she have to say about anything oh
my god but jojo she wasn't not boring i
wasn't boring at 16. i was hella fun i
was a stripper at 16. you were sucking
or whatever i wasn't technically yet
yeah i definitely was but not for money
not for money but at the same time like
not everyone's gonna like you what
i can't say that you're boring you're
boring you can say she's boring yeah
she still is like they're just so like
but whatever
like please stop talking about me i just
you're not a very nice person
sorry i don't know you well in her she
you're not you've not been nice to her
she's right about that
because first of all i couldn't care
less like i couldn't care less like
honestly couldn't care less it was a
viral thing
i'm a little like that's what i do i
like just react like it's not like i was
like attacking him yeah yeah i look i
think that madness i'm a very nice
person
i am just when you're not no i'm just
like a little but like i can't comment
on things
i think in her my i'm just gonna i'm
trying to tell me to play on her side
here because i do think
like she's she's 16 she's not very
mature and she's really hurt because
people are dog piling people are
are uns following her on tick tock and
she's just she's
it's a lot to process and so she sees
you as the avatar of this whole movement
and she says
[ __ ] you right for sure and can i say i
don't know if you have these tick tocks
but after that
and i went on live too to say this i was
like you know what she's a 16 girl like
and for me i've like played into it i
bought into it i was like you know what
it is a lot for a 16 year old like i
probably would [ __ ] be like oh my god
like on the day
i was on the defense my whole life up
until like 30 up until now actually
and so i said to her i literally
apologize i was like girl i am sorry
like i heard your feelings i did this
was before james charles
that dumb little prick chimed in but
then this girl is like oh [ __ ] she's
like really going through it i'm so
sorry because maybe she like watched my
videos maybe she was like a fan and she
was like sad that i just said that and i
totally get it so i apologize
until james [ __ ] child okay so
here we go now james charles shows up
oh wait you apologize first should i
watch this you apologize to her
yeah yeah watch that please okay so
trisha now apologizes
i have thoughts to charlie charlie
you're a minor i sincerely apologize
for hurting your feelings in any
capacity at that age i know it could
feel like
the worst thing in the world what you're
going through now may feel like the
whole world is crashing down on you but
you still have a chance to have a really
amazing career
what you did in the actual video wasn't
that horrible you weren't being hateful
or spiteful you were being a 16 year old
yeah
it was it was bad behavior as bratty
behavior i know you realize that now you
show true remorse
and i think that's great growth and
for my part i sincerely apologize for
hurting your feelings or offending you
in incapacity not my intention
i cannot imagine being 16 with the
amount of eyes you have on you
i hope that you continue to grow and i
hope that you know that you are so
worthy of life
and you are so worthy of love and you
are so worthy of what you had
like i said what you did was very minor
people just wanted you
to take accountability you did and for
my part i'm sorry
okay so yeah she gets on and says i'm so
sorry i supposed to dixie he's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] my parents are great
whatever so to me i was like you know
what she's like
for 16 being mature and i was like this
is whatever i thought her
i thought her response was much sweeter
than her sister of course so then i was
like [ __ ] and then like i know when i
was 16 like if someone i like
knew on the internet like [ __ ] call
me out or whatever i'd be like [ __ ] yeah
that like doesn't feel good
so okay cool you apologize you're like
it's done
but then all of a sudden hi sister
sister snatch the god complex on the
internet
james come in like i've
actually never like been so grossed out
by someone's ugliness
on the inside so much hi sisters
oh well you know i'm no friend of james
charles i
i was cool with james but after i talked
to him in the dm's i was like this
[ __ ]
douche hi sister
james is like super challenged at makeup
like why does he go down the road
like the path of like keemstar being
like a troll and an [ __ ] like why is
he like i don't think he's a troll
i think he's like a well again i'm not i
can't diagnose him but he's got
he's got you know a big ego and he's and
he's very
victim complex yeah he gets very
defensive apologized like even being
called out for like racist stuff he's
done he's still not apologizing
all right let's read the tweet this
charlie situation does not sit right
with me
is that good or yeah 100 million
followers of one year
and you all he's got kind of a deep
voice too it's like 100 million
followers of one year and you all expect
her to know how to be a perfect role
model
death rush because she's a picky eater
major joke about a milestone three plus
years old dragging half their age
feels familiar oh because he's saying
he's been through it
yeah because tati was friends with him
which by the way i don't know these
people yeah it's not familiar
like the fact that your parents let you
hang out with tati when you were a
teenager that was something about your
parenting and i'm sorry you were the
victim of that but at the same time now
you're a victim so
i feel like his tweet was fine i feel
like these are all good points to make
that i agree with
but the feels familiar part is like okay
victim
yeah i agree with that perpetual victim
feels familiar
sister sister snatch
death threats i mean yeah it's like but
this is also what people say when they
want to try and cop out of something
like i used to say all the time like i'm
kidding death thoughts
everybody gets death that's funny you
say that
it is because everybody gets death
throat everybody it's those little
fairies that are like hanging yourself
like whatever
it's also like an 11 year old email
that's like i [ __ ] gonna kill you
yeah if someone's like taking pictures
of your house and like what that's like
one thing but like
saying nine year olds are gonna kill you
like that's a that's the internet now
okay so sister snatch and then you
respond
to james which of course you have to
because [ __ ] james charles am i right
okay you buried it you apologize and now
james got to insert himself
into the drama and make up all about
james charles
that's what i [ __ ] can't say let's go
stop diagnosing him but that's what a
narcissist does
without diagnosing this narcissist who
inserts himself into drama after she's
apologized i apologize people are
getting over it
but no this is ultimate deflection
narcissist
oh james that's why i kind of feel like
he had something to do with her stop
calling me up because she called me out
the same way james did which is like
keep my name out of your mouth
and i was like what the [ __ ] and now
james is like here's my chance to jump
in forever victims
james charles sub tweeted this about me
30 plus year old dragging someone half
their age
hey you young kids and kittens the
reason why you're so rich is because
people talk about you
i'm allowed to comment on people i've
never even met before i wasn't a 30 year
old being friends with you james
underage
you are also 21 years old friends with
an underage
minor tati took advantage of you by
being friends with you
you're doing that with charlie i haven't
been friends with you i haven't been
friends with charlie i have not friends
with a minor
i'm simply someone on social media and
giving comments and just because you
don't like me james
that by the way that this whole
relationship he has with her like
being a mentor is nice and good but that
when he's
having her like promote his merch and
stuff then it feels a little
user a little parasitic it's the same
way tati was using him and he's using
her and
that's really interesting i i think
you're right i mean
don't don't put her in your merch
campaign right it's gross it's
i would never like my merch coming out
not to plug it but i would never be like
shane wear this you know like i think
charlie yeah exactly you know yeah you
don't put them in charlie i'm doing i
want you to
wear my merch yeah it's something i've
done i've done so i'm not comfortable
i've done
so much for you i'm your mentor i'm your
mentor you wouldn't be anything without
me
what the fact that he called himself
remember charlie also came after me
because those words were exactly the
words that came out of your mouth keep
my name out of here because someone who
needs a mentor be a mentor
i don't know you gotta mentor james
maybe you shouldn't jim mentor i'll
meant to off
no i've got too many
i've got a son i don't need a disciple
james would you like to be my disciple
oh i'm gonna keep talking about you
as long as you're on social media people
are open for criticism
there's no hate there's no bullying
there's no foul
misconduct except for you being friends
with a 16 year old girl
okay so hold on hold on hold on now
trisha before you comment
somebody pointed this out and i just
have to in the sake of fairness
you have made a bunch of videos okay
yeah first uh
jokes once one day
oh this was all in one day okay so
what's the deal
okay i will tell you and i said this on
tick tock and i'll say it right now
when i collab to jojo her parents
weren't home and i was like what the
[ __ ] like i felt so
weird immediately i was like you know i
like
it it felt weird it felt weird so then
we did collabs david and jason came over
her parents still were home like this
feels
it felt weird from the beginning it
feels what can we [ __ ] us up with their
face wait so
not only you but david and jason were
there and her parents were there
what and it was weird so okay they
weren't even at home huh
they weren't even there like in the
house no
and it felt so weird and i get like so
no it does and here look can i also just
say i'll
finish the story of the jojo like i had
issues when i was a kid obviously with
adults young adults that like [ __ ] me
up you know and less than me and not
just straight guys okay and whatever
so and not just males so i have a really
deep rooted
sense of like trauma from this and 98 of
adults probably aren't doing weird [ __ ]
you don't need to quantify that you
shouldn't leave your
your your young daughter alone with
three of course adults
of course okay but i'm just i want
people to know why i'm so adamant about
this because it [ __ ] me up in such
a way that like i can't even explain so
so i
felt weird and right away but anyway so
fast forward to new year's eve i'm
dating jason
she invites us to go to new year's eve
with her and and that and i did a whole
video about this of why i was alone on
new year's eve i told jason i don't feel
comfortable like going to a new year's
eve
queen tribute band with a minor like i
just don't even if he has kids or
whatever like i just i didn't feel
i didn't feel comfortable so i didn't go
and i said that in my new year's eve
video look it up in 2019 why i was alone
on new year's eve it's a video up
and i just never felt comfortable with
it so i i did i did it and it felt
so weird and i think at the time
especially during this time i was just
like
oh you know same thing getting followers
and stuff and you don't think it's a big
deal until you're in it and then i was
like this is so
why can't you give james the benefit of
the doubt because you did that i did it
once he's like
best friends hanging out with this girl
multiple times except like alone
and uh to me and like i said chances are
there's nothing like that happening but
it's no it's inappropriate
it's like to me hanging out with being
best friends like i said to mentor or
even having a video like let's say we
have like a minor on our podcast or
whatever
and their parents are here whatever but
to hang out with them consistently
either whether it's using them for views
or whatever it's it's just
21. and she's 16. wow that's a pretty
big age gap
it's a very big age yeah especially
because she just turned 16
and and you're not developed at that age
you're just not mentally there
you're gonna listen of course she's
already corrupted there she tweeted her
like hi best friend and she's like hi
best friend there's this weird
manipulation going on
there and i i don't like it i don't like
it i think it's i think it's
inappropriate
so let me let me i was gonna say well
maybe he's friends with the sister
that's what he was saying i'm friends
with the family but hold on because if
you go to the classroom drop
her sister's not in the photo shoot it's
just charlie
and she's front and center front and
center she's like
the the main focus of the photo shoot
with him
they're best friends it's so gross that
like whole thing he's
she was 15 at the time yep freak
it is it is there's there's just no
reason for that there's just it's just
not it's inappropriate
okay a little bit hypocritical here but
i i think you make a decent point oh i'm
not
can i just always say i have never even
with the n word i never want to be like
i'm so much better than them like i have
thought i think first of all you did a
collab with her
james is like hank is like using this
girl to promote merch and like
with her all the time it's it makes me
to this day it makes me still so
uncomfortable and stuff and it's so so i
never
want to be like i'm so much better than
them like why did you stay at
her house when her parents were there it
was so odd
sorry well at the time i didn't know oh
bless you so
her mom let me correct this her mom
actually was there when i came in she
was bedazzling stuff and i we bling
stuff out until we were like doing and
then i think she just left or something
i
like that's how it was and um yeah it's
it's
it's weird it was so weird and like i'll
be an ugly advocate i've talked about it
before why i don't like hang out with
her anymore and stuff and i think i
think it's
extremely like you know i mean other
other adults hang out with her and stuff
i
just think it's weird i don't and it's
also not good for the child that's why
child stars get [ __ ] up right
they're hanging around all these adults
and it's like there's something that's
[ __ ] them up whether it's like
they're growing up too fast i don't know
there's a lot yeah there's a there's
plenty there that could [ __ ] him up so
james responds to you
let's [ __ ] get into the that james
charles is the victim in
every single [ __ ] you i didn't want to
remember
electricity wait you know what i have a
funny idea i'm going to play this in
slow
motion i'm going to turn the speed down
on youtube i don't know you could do
that that's so cool
let's see playback speed um let's do 75
james charles oh [ __ ] you i didn't want
to respond to this because they didn't
want to get [ __ ] normal
it's on slow motion right now so weird
tricks to the attention that she's
clearly
craving however i've never been accused
of being a child groomer and this is not
an accusation
yeah you never said grooming is so
different so different
why are you saying groomer this whole
thing is just so many mistruths which is
what fired me up more than anything
i'm like don't lie on me like you
there's nothing you didn't say groomer
because that's crazy to say that it's
the groomer grooming is also weird you
said it's just contouring
like even like regardless like whatever
like grooming is such a whole other
thing that's like
bringing someone up to be like onision
does to like the 17th yeah
yeah no group wait hold on abe did she
call him a groomer because i definitely
not
just i want to make that clear i don't
recall her calling yeah okay
i would be like i don't know maybe but
maybe maybe groomers in your head james
he has the voices in his head no that's
like that is a subconscious thing i was
like what the [ __ ] like your group like
yeah grooming indicates you're prepping
them for like
yeah you take a candle to take a candle
okay not bad to be like a little show
pony in your sister's campaign
okay here we go and then i'm gonna take
lightly uh to enjoy
the relationship between charlie and ice
anything other than just a friendship is
absolutely disgusting i don't need
charlie and charlie does not need me
you most definitely need front row and
center of the school
shoot she doesn't need me i'm just like
she definitely doesn't need you
that's for sure definitely meet her yeah
i mean you've definitely
you used her the first chance you could
to put her in the front row center we
got like a second win like people were
over james even even the tatty think
whatever [ __ ] i don't like her
either but like people were kind of over
him anyways and then he got this
resurgence with this tick-tocker and he
was like stuck in the blood of these
young
underage by the way he's in his sister
rome with the blue eyeshadow just i
became friends with the millionaire
family as a whole
very very why weren't any of them in
your school shoot
right sounds very familiar tati also
saying she was friends with his whole
family that her
his parents were before dinner it's very
aren't they ever why aren't they ever in
your tick tocks and [ __ ]
very very new to them and i wanted to be
a french and i mentor in any way that i
possibly could
and charlie and i despite not being the
same age had one thing in common
which is coming into the spotlight at a
very very young age
this is something that trisha has never
experienced because the only reason she
is in the spotlight
is because she has said racist things
she said the n-word she's done blackfish
she offended the trans community she
offended the did community
she said hitler wasn't that bad of a guy
voted for trump wait what did you say
about hitler he said hitler wasn't that
bad
is that from this show no i think that
was from like maybe i have no idea maybe
i said it in like a video why i have no
idea i was like because all i've been
saying on this show is like i'm really
traumatized with what hitler did like
now that i've like watched like 45
minutes of schindler's list i'm like wow
he's
really sucky that's all i've been saying
is how much i hate hitler recently
so i'm like and it started to fight with
about every single other creator on
this platform that's my favorite you are
when she has a fight with every single
other creator on this platform like i
like i
i just talk about people like what the
[ __ ] it's not like i have an issue do
you think i like
i mean no you go through a lot of beefs
but do i wake up so does james
yeah he's like no position to be talking
about me and my career so i highly
recommend that you stop starting fights
with people that are half your age
pack it up and work on holding yourself
and your best friends around you because
they and you are the problem oh okay
whoa everyone was saying james ended you
he really did something he did something
there and that by the way just a
reminder that it's not let me play it
back at full speed now
watch this just so you can get a sense
for how fast you start
take lightly uh to insinuate the
relationship between charlie and i
anything other than just a friendship is
absolutely
disgusting i don't need charlie and
charlie does not need me i became
friends
i mean look he's like basically he's
just being like you know what you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
for sure but you know what i made him
look so first of all
of course i'm trash of the internet like
this is why people
i'm like this is my thing it's getting
canceled like so for him to point out
stuff from like ten years ago like okay
cool
but now he just made himself look like
an ass because now what remember those
tweets he did about like going to africa
and like where he's gonna get ebola
did you see those so there's a ton of
racist tweets that came out about him
and his excuse right did you see his
apology about it well actually he didn't
apologize
his excuse he writes to the person like
hey hold up pull it up baby
with receipts let's go so a few years
ago james was cancelled for saying all
africa has
ebola and also making this racist
comment that like they're going to
africa and he and his friends are going
to get ebola
okay wait pause the whole thing
should we discuss the tweet she's going
to tell you she's explaining it right
now
i don't know if you guys remember ebola
but there was a lot of racism toward
african-americans at the time because of
it like treating them like they were
dirty and diseased and his tweet just
added to that
okay this comment about how some stupid
indian man didn't have his size at the
boardwalk
he was just he was a chubby block wait i
want to read the tweet she went too fast
okay
he says wait hold on dude this girl came
with the receipts
i gotta hire her i know you're fired
baby okay she said
wow i really wanted a cute yellow minion
sweatshirt for 10 bucks but no they
didn't have my size stupid indian man on
the boardwalk
i've never once there's not one tweeted
me saying dumb asians don't know how to
draw like
what like an indian okay and he said
there's no value
to bring a brace in general there's
malice behind a stereotype or something
so it's so
[ __ ] crazy like it there's no matter
how you meet anyways okay
i agree i agree what yours is from
though
he was seventeen he said when he said
these black women okay i wish i was a
chubby black woman who sing in a
barbershop style
acapella group
okay here's my take just put race into
anything
there's some stereotype you're trying to
project with that like
it doesn't need to be said now you know
what i mean it doesn't need to be said
like ever but it's like you don't just
say like oh
i wish i was a black woman or a black
man or it's just like a weird
there's some sort of motivation behind
it it is it is racist in my opinion i
don't think you should say that like
okay
barbershop style acapella group which is
such a racist stereotype
posted this picture shaming a black
woman for her hairstyle taking a picture
of her in public and posting it on his
feed to shame her what the hell
wait what was the photo i saw you said
what the hell this is not okay but what
was the
black woman with her hair done oh that's
her bun what's wrong with that
what's this oh so this is the worst he
took a random photo of someone in public
and posted to his twitter feed that's
insane he said
what the hell this is not okay like that
is super
that is super [ __ ] crazy to just call
out some random person
i don't see what's wrong what's wrong
with her hairstyle it's just a bun yeah
what's wrong with that i don't want a
mocker it's just like when people do it
at jeff
but i'm genuinely curious what is he
saying is not okay he's just i guess he
doesn't like it he doesn't think it's
attractive
is the bun is the fabric made of
something probably she looks like she
has like maybe hair extensions or
something that don't blend right
oh it's in the discord if you want
better visuals the second link has those
all those tweets
that's okay this is fun pictures shaming
a black woman for her hairstyle taking a
picture of her in public yeah that's
funny
[ __ ] up shame her that's megan i was
calling slow walkers annoying and he was
called out for being ableist
oh [ __ ] sorry annoying and he was called
out
my fat [ __ ] fingers i see you
retweeted this
do you hate james charles more than
anyone um
i wouldn't say i hate him i think if
anyone deserves to be canceled off the
internet it definitely should be him
i don't believe that people can be
canceled you have to go away to be
canceled but
he deserves to be canceled more than
anybody because he's this is the
influence of like
it's not the generation his age like 21
or even teenagers it's like the 9 and 10
year olds who think this is like cool
and they look up to him it's like oh
this is like not good okay
okay so he so he quote tweeted somebody
saying hmm some of us have chronic pain
and other disabilities and have no other
choice but to walk slow
if i walk fast i'll collapse and then
you'll have to walk around a sobbing
mess
he tweeted that and said this was the
most annoying tweet of the century
why and this was 2018 so he's 19.
why would you diss on this poor disabled
person
i have a disability he's like most
annoying tweet okay let's continue real
quick
that's not proof he's racist though well
here's the thing it's like this is the
thing it's like
consistent behavior i said the n word in
a song 10 years ago and he wants to call
me out for that fine
i agree that's what i'm saying he
shouldn't be calling anyone out for
being racist
for something small like singing you
know that's like
you saying the n-word when you're
singing a song or something let's face
it we've all done in private at one
point in our time so for him to call you
up for that
is like super silly no but then to be
like
this like this is insane this isn't
saying to me tweet of the century
he also got in trouble for calling his
mexican friend his slave oh good call
wait let me read that headline
fast in a video and he has the same
pattern of concern this stuff is all
good this is why you shouldn't call
anyone out for being racist
james charles that would be like me
calling out someone for like oh you're
right like
why like first of all i'm like never
saying if you're a white guy you might
not want to call your mexican friend
your slave
what was i'd love to know the context of
that i mean maybe
maybe can you look that one up yeah i'm
on it
and you know what's so great is he's now
latched onto this new generation with
tick tock
so the people who wouldn't have known
about this it's not being brought to
light because of your dumb ass trying to
call me out and thinking you really did
something right when in reality and you
know what
the worst part of this is so he's
getting called out by so many like
different
like ethnicities whatever it doesn't
matter he's getting called out and
instead of like again
apologizing like yeah my n-word thing
keeps getting brought up and i like
said sorry i say sorry he's like i'll
take accountability but it wasn't under
malice but i was 17. it's like that's
not accountability if you make excuses
the fact that he can't say i'm [ __ ]
sorry
and go on tick-tock the way he called me
out and tell his people like hey this is
[ __ ]
he should know if he really matured and
apologizing whatever he knows he
shouldn't call you
but i'm saying if he's like oh i was 17.
he should know now not to call you out
for doing something but the picture he
took of the black woman and making fun
of her bun is
[ __ ] up on so many levels so many
levels to shame anybody that's like
there was
a guy at the gym took a picture of like
a fat that's exactly what that is
it's like she's not she's not part of
your life you don't know her to put her
on the internet like that to me is
so gross but that just shows like the
ugliness in him just like seeps out
and all the stuff like i didn't know
about any of this stuff so as soon as i
saw i'm like
this guy is actually disgusting and this
is why he's hated because i never
understood it like i heard stuff
from you shane jeffrey whatever tati and
i was just like okay
he sounds shitty but then now and i've
never met him to see all this i'm like
he's an actual like
can i you know it's funny whenever we
put out a new uh release
on uh teddy fresh the comments are
always um james
uh sneak peek of james strahl's next
collection
wait is there more you ended it oh there
was like a couple seconds i think she
was just saying i don't know let's see
i'm i'm super into a video slave so
don't tell me that james and trisha
because he talked fast in a video and he
has the same pattern of consistent
raises behavior as trisha did
she's good she's [ __ ] mm-hmm and can
i just say not the same pattern for
consistent mine was not consistent oh
she's right here
no but she's right that's what i'm gonna
say you guys are both racist in the same
way
you're not really consistent he has like
consistent
the big thing in the uk is racism they
don't let you on that show if you're
like a little bit racist so they do like
in-depth like research to see if you
were like racist at any point if they
like let me on somebody big brother
where they kick people off for being
racist
like i'm not it's not consistent so
you're so your
evidence that you're not racist is that
you're on big brother there's no
consistency
about me ever saying that do you know i
don't think you're racist i don't think
he's necessarily racist he starts like
dancing to the end
i'm getting to that but yeah are we
though because i feel like dan's gonna
cut us off guys
no no no we're get we're covering all
this [ __ ] we warned everyone this is
gonna be a 10 hour episode
i love that we're here for the dirt the
tea is hot
like andy i can keep having to pee i'm
just going crack right
okay so it gets me like so worked up
like it just makes me so mad that
hypocrisy so james responds to you and
then you respond to james here we are
oh man this is this is a wild [ __ ]
ride they want to call me out for
skeletons in my closet ten years ago
which are out
it's not a secret i've apologized
numerous times but it's cool i'll
apologize again i shouldn't have said
the n word um now james accused me of
being also a trump supporter
among other false allegations saying
that i voted for trump was his specific
words
i'm a registered when did he say that
she voted for trump like
oh really he was talking so fast i
missed it never voted for trump
right in this year when i talked about
trump years ago i never even voted now
why is that not okay i think have your
political police i'm open
whatever you want to do but dixie's dad
is a literal politician to me it was the
ultimate slam dunk
because her dad is a mega guy and he's
like
they're best friends with the family so
what yeah i mean
like dude her your best friend
apparently is magga and you're calling
trisha
as a point against her that she voted
for trump in 2016. you're bashing me by
saying i'm a trump supporter yeah this
was uh
i this was one of these you're cool
being friends with the family
sometimes i hit sometimes i miss you
know i throw it all out there
and again i'm not i'm not saying
anything about the family i'm just it's
mostly a comment about
james being a [ __ ] dumbass i think
their parents absolutely suck for like
with this right now but
like anyways can't keep climbing well
def they're definitely riding the gravy
train
oh for sure they're like oh did you see
him reacting to
he's like dixie is dramatic like they're
like playing off their reactions
at all i'm like your kids don't seem
like they're in crisis online but you're
gonna like make it a joke it's so weird
i'd be like you know what it looks like
chill on the internet it's like
trisha responds okay so you'd responded
to james i'm getting oh
jeffrey starr gets involved i was
confused i felt like jeffree star was
i feel like called out by jeffree star a
little bit me or james
me everyone oh cause he isn't he okay
let's watch i
am i guess yesterday there was a bunch
of drama with other people
not involving me but people still wanna
um
mention my name first of all i have no
idea what happened
i don't give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
this filter bro can you
like what [ __ ] like holy
god dude you gotta chill out i love this
he goes i don't give a [ __ ] but also let
me talk about it
busy worrying about myself
my family um and i don't care i don't
entertain it so
um if you were friends with me and
you're not anymore keep my
name out of your mouth jesus also the
depression
yeah very scary because as someone who's
always was like a hot head i've like
grown out of my aggressiveness i feel
like the way i like react to james i
used to like go off and be like you
stupid no but james
i mean jeffree star is the type of dude
to hire an assassin
a thousand percent like the aggression
so wait who's he talking to so that's
the thing so definitely said james
charles but
my theory you think it's you i think
it's me i think he was talking about
yeah i think he's talking about you and
me because he was saying if you were
friends and we're not anymore keep my
name because
someone said oh maybe it was james who
said and be responsible for the people
around you
but i think that he said you're friends
but i thought he was referring to shane
and you
because you guys have whatever issue
whatever
and so because i don't like him right
and i don't even know him and i never
did
and so i think he was referring because
people like people during this like heat
or whatever they love to throw like well
you're friends with shane or whatever
you think i'm on jeffrey's hit list
um i don't think so
no he doesn't like me there's no way i
don't think he's an issue do you think
he has a hit list
i don't think he has who's on a hit list
if he had like a like metaphorically
speaking
sure the list on his phrase it says kill
these people
probably james no not kill i'm just
saying like metaphorical list of people
he doesn't like in his head
i don't know this but i would just say
probably like james tati
manny laura oh my god he's ready to take
them all out
i mean but don't we all have a
metaphorical like listener hat or people
we don't really
want to kill no this is a bible this is
actually the longer one did than i
thought okay
oh jesus christ this is hard this is
like literally like you know in the
beginning of the bible it's like
trisha begat charles and charles we got
jeffrey and jeffrey beget dixie it's
like holy [ __ ]
this is what we should have started with
because now it's like this is the juicy
part like like i said the snail thing at
the beginning we spent so much time
talking about it well that's
that was the whole genesis that was the
garden of eden i mean what the [ __ ] in
the beginning
god said let there be light and dixie
said let there be
bulimia or whatever i don't know i don't
know i'm sorry
trigger warning believe me okay so
jeffrey gets involved then trisha calls
out charlie's parents and james charles
the [ __ ]
the chapters going on charlie called i
love by the way this microphone thing
everyone does on tick-tock with their
headphones it's so fun i don't even need
the microphone because my house is so
quiet but i like to use it for effect
that's when you know shit's real i'm
tick-tock that's what people do like hey
guys
lee is a minor so i'm going to try and
just
handle this with literal kid gloves
because she has a child and
i understand that it's concerning
how her parents raised her and that
she's hanging out with james charles
because now she has adopted james
charles mentality
of the keep my name out of your mouth
she told me to stop
talking about her she's been rude
when she's literally the most followed
person on social media that's what she
signed up for
um and i haven't been rude i've given
constructive criticism uh as far as this
situation goes because i really do feel
for her and i do think it is uh her
parents
poor raising that gave them the manners
that they have
and she because they were in the
category of their parents you have to
watch the kids
definitely a great one like it wasn't
just this clip like they were
so i feel like this video is very like
huh i i feel like this video's a bit
much you're like trying to like make
this big point about her whole family
it's just not that serious i never said
it was
i mean i got that i got at the creator
fund i got bills to pay you know
right okay fair enough yeah
did you this is mine you must have
killed it on the creator
are you comfortable sharing no what is
you in the money thing i'm just asking
i'm not pressuring you
but i'm sure you were crushing it like
holy god rushing it i
loved it i had 250 million views that
day oh
that tick tock is crazy like that's like
the population 250 million views in one
day
so you were just like i don't care if
everyone hates me can i peek at your
earnings i won't say it i promise oh the
earnings is not comparable to views the
the ratio of money per views on there so
like
how much of these videos was motivated
by wanting views and how much was
motivated by actually being outraged
the outrage didn't kick in until like
james came in
and then you're like this was before
james that video you to show was also
before james so i was like okay like let
me explain myself because it
blew up so big like charlie just ended
you so i was like okay let me just try
were you kind of excited when james
responded because you're like views
all day let's go oh for sure even when
johnny mentioned me like
what the hell let's go kind of like a
fever dream i was like wow 100 million
follower girl is like calling me out
like oh my god like this is the most
relevant i've been in a while too i love
it
like this is how i thrive so that's
eating the chicken that's kind of
exactly dude ah they fed the troll but
like and i'm not that person let me see
your stuff wow
i won't say anything okay so they're
kind of behind
so that was the day but then they they
can i say how many views you got in the
last seven days
um yeah 400 million in the last seven
days
that is insane okay so the money but the
money wasn't dry everyone's like wow
she's really killing i mean the money
like compared to what i make on
like only fans is like not nothing hold
on as of today you have 3.8 million your
followers have been insane too how do
you how do i see how many followers you
get every day
i don't think you can i think it's just
you can see like a spike
my spike was up when everyone was trying
to cancel charlie and they came for me
and then it like went down
yeah but it's still up a lot for sure um
and then i'll show you what i made but
like i mean don't i won't say but it's
also
to me this is literally not click the
button come on i promise you it's like
okay so there's
that's really good i mean that's it for
the 150 million views you know
well yeah well no but i mean it's all
it's good money it's real money
for sure like the amount of money you
made in the past month
oh that's like your lifetime earnings
yeah but i only started monetizing when
you did which was mid-september
that's good money yeah well their cpm is
like two cents per thousand views so
it's kind of insane like people are i
don't think they're getting rich
maybe some people like people yeah not
many people not like but not me
like to me it's like if tick-tock banned
my account i want to be like oh my god
my life's over
like you know that's that's really good
money though i mean it's money in the
bank
it's less than my transgender video that
you called me out on
no yeah oh in that one day yeah you're
right well not even a date
okay so anyway um i feel like you
stretched a little thing here i'll be
honest with you but then dixie responds
okay so then
getting so many views normally my tick
tock said like half a million to a
million i was getting like
12 million on these responses so i was
like well let's go
no wonder you made 50 videos of course i
was like this is like
this is amazing dixie and charles take
no don't feed the troll they're the most
subscribers on tick tock i was like so
excited
i was like i was kind of surprised that
charlie called you out
you having your drink at dunkin girl
like i'm adam
vibrator is like girl don't stoop to
this level
like do you know what you mean like
that'd be like me like entertaining like
perez hilton when he talks about me or
like
peter mon or some drama channel that's
like nobody knows you know what i mean
rich locks although i like rich but you
know
but your videos i think that your videos
were getting a lot of views
yeah so she was like yeah but okay so so
this is when [ __ ] gets really weird
so the sister dixie who's 19 i think so
she made this video trying to diss
tricia in it back for a big time this
was a really bad move by her
i think she's like i'm on top of the
world i'm going to bury this [ __ ] and
she really [ __ ] up here
straight from the underground a young
lady got a bag cause i'm brown
and not the other color so police think
they have the authority look at that
killing minorities
smile okay she did it she goes
look at me [ __ ] so this is the sound
bite from 10 years ago where you said
the n word
you're singing the song 10 years ago and
she's like oh
i'm gonna dance to this whichever 2020
the year of black lives matter you know
what can i just say i don't hate the
younger generation i hate tick tockers
right now because the younger generation
in general is very woke
they got bited into office you know they
did the black lives matter movement like
i think they're really woke and like i
honestly do like learn from them
but like these influencers that are just
so like holier than that like i have i'm
superior already it's like
this is insane that this happened in
2020 i was like are you so tone
definitely
i think she thought but like the the way
that she like used that like she used
the n-word in that way to like try to
it's like yeah yeah we get i mean yeah
it was totally a low blow
okay it's not a low blow that's like
like retardation not to be mean like i
don't know about why get canceled for
saying that but
like there is something a little off
with her right wait you just called her
[ __ ]
but i think there's something like maybe
off with her yeah but but that's an
offensive word
no but i think there's an actual
slowness there yeah but [ __ ] is a
derogatory word you use a derogatory but
i'm saying like she's actually like slow
no but you don't say that word anymore
it's derogatory
no i know but i'm not trying to be
politically correct okay i
i apologize but do you understand what
the difference dan i don't need you
calling me out here
okay here's the thing i think she's i
think she might be like off
i'm not saying that to mean i think she
might be off because you could call her
slow but if you use the r word it's rude
i apologize yeah please don't cancel
well i just
it's just ironic that you're saying it
when you're like you can't but but
they're not the same no it's totally not
the same should be like
and then she tags the creator of the
dance she's doing the renegade
at the first place she they stole the
dance they're notorious for stealing
dances they stole this dance without
crediting it was a huge channel last
time
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on calm down
a b a b a b james charles commented on
this video where's all this [ __ ] antana
tana who screamed the hard r with you
stupid [ __ ] n-word
oh dude what i said get her
how stupid oh trish is going up
against the ball for the double and this
happens
we saw it from the beginning with the
maybe i need the comments in that video
the maker crew the the the o12 boys the
meg con boys
the vlog squad they all have their
moment and then they go down and crash
away
blog squad they're huge no they're all
all their views are down nobody cares
about the data
david's not posting right so all the all
of them the
posse the vlog spot david is popping
whatever yeah the crew
90 000 views like no one cares so
really it's so great go to go to toddy
smith
go to scotty's size who are these people
nobody cares anymore
and it's so [ __ ] oh my god calm down
so no because let me tell you
when there are shitty people getting the
spotlight remember meg con boys taylor
knifed contact of course you don't
because who the [ __ ] are you i don't
know who they are do you remember like
the maker crew the people who started
maker
that louis vuitton yeah i just saw the
lv
it's just like i can't wait to see these
people everyone makes fun of me for
being 32 doing this
i would love to see that calm down calm
down calm down
mitchell uh what's his name calm down
what are these people grace helbig
remember them they were so comfortable
tyler on down okay wait why are you why
are you laughing on tap
tap dancing on their graves oh no grace
was a [ __ ] vidcon oh my god
wait we can't say that word you can't
say the c word damn [ __ ] [ __ ]
remember to say the c word a [ __ ]
those people and the fact that they're
out
well they'll give us notes i guess for
her to talk down to me back then being
like no one gets oh my god no one gets a
snake
canceled you no one listens to your
shitty podcast
click baiting dan levy from shit's creek
trish is doing a lap around the track
right now i can't wait for this to
happen
to the lair reyes to the tana to the
james
charles i cannot wait for this to happen
i'm going to be wendy williams still
hated
you guys will be nobodies james charles
is way bigger than like
uh tyler tyler oaker
no tyler was like on ellen he had that
documentary about him like tyler
some people stopped caring about tyler
oakley because didn't you see his
documentary's nervous he didn't have the
final edit on it
and it made him he was an [ __ ] to
people he literally like spilled juice
but clean it up
what is that what ruined his career yeah
why he didn't have final edit so the
director did it they made him look he
was [ __ ]
so what was the name of his documentary
nervous look it up oh my goodness i
didn't i see i was i never
what does nervous mean i have no idea
like who the [ __ ] knows the same thing
with like
oh it's beautiful it's beautiful 5.5
stars
yo they [ __ ] him over and that is
[ __ ] him over
okay whatever who cares about tyler
oakley yeah yeah who gives a [ __ ]
like other people like too okay stop it
let me focus you're like
everywhere i'm trying to [ __ ] tell a
story here and we're talking about tyler
oakley
he i know he probably loves baby what
was i waiting for
i want comments comments well she
deleted the video so i can't see all the
comments but i got on her apology
i sent him the discord and you can see a
lot of people are upset what are you
looking for comments on
on the [ __ ] on the video where she
showed you saying the n word there was
like james charles and tanaka oh
i got that i got it i got it i got it
okay so so this is perfect yeah this is
thanks again to credit death noodles
we're just getting all this
noodles is the man i love him he's so on
it he he screenshotted this and um i
appreciate so this was on dixie's
her dancing to the n-word in 2020. okay
so you've got people like james charles
says get her
tan emoji said oh my god she didn't say
she said oh my god you said she said
something i guess he said get her okay
but james charles to say that i was like
yeah but but yeah batana to comment on
this tana
be quiet oh my god i
yeah i just like omg you think she
should just kind of maybe
yeah let's do one of those because you
know what when other people are in [ __ ]
i don't really like insert myself
because like
i'm problematic i'm sure you've done
that what
insert yourself in drama not like
intentionally like
i don't like to me this wasn't drama i
saw this video i was like let me do it
and get views
okay okay so anyway it's hilarious that
they inserted themselves and then she
erased the video when she was getting
uh [ __ ] for it and so she said
the heart r and the n word in an
aggressive way to black people tana
dixie but i saw it
dixie demilio uh 19 year old
dancing to a sound of me singing the n
word from an nwa song
i was 22 at the time i'm 32 now so 10
years old
definitely apologize for that video
numerous times
i'll continue apologize because it's
gross saying the n word is gross but
here
here's what trips my trigger dixie was
dancing
to a song with the end we're not bleeped
yesterday oh yeah i remember they said
the word ten years ago
how come you and your sister have done
multiple dances
to the n-word just because you go yeah
yeah i want to see that okay
also also she's this is her first excuse
was like i made my point so i deleted it
and then she was getting called out and
she was i'm sorry i shouldn't have done
it but she was trying to make it like i
deleted it because i already made my
point right
i win yeah but it was like no wait so
these girls do this dance they've done
it a bunch of times
where they dance to a song saying the n
word and then they do this
which is super weird they go and then
the n word drops and they go
like don't uh yeah it's super weird
so weird i think it's super bizarre
it's so bizarre and it's so [ __ ]
weird and like
it's just and okay so let's work through
this this is like a [ __ ] bible i mean
come on
just responds saying the sound okay so
then blah blah blah
yadda yadda dixie responds tristan
responds where the [ __ ]
am i dixie responds with the tick tocks
of her dancing
we saw that trisha responds we saw this
trisha now you share a video of them
saying the n word which is
which appears to be fake dude so
you kind of did a fake news here oh did
i you didn't know that
look at their face
to reiterate last night dixie danced to
a sound of me saying that was fake news
you did a total fake news how can i
uh look at the comments they didn't even
say it quit trish
i'm dead they didn't even see you i
would like to submit a retraction you're
obsessed oh my god
they didn't even say it girl you were
obsessed at this point
they didn't even say it low she really
trying to cancel them they didn't even
say it left myself trish she didn't say
it hahaha give it up sis you're done
forever oh damn they didn't even say it
et cetera et cetera
it was like the [ __ ] whole little
rascals came attacking this weekend it
was [ __ ] insane
well you can't share a video saying they
said the animal was like i'm just doing
a retraction right now
we'll delete it look at look at that
look at this look how dumb it looks
my apologies to the demeanor
you did not say the well you'd answer
the n word but you didn't say it you
didn't say it so i guess that's
okay so there we go we have a retraction
you weaponized it
well they didn't you haven't is racist
and anti-black
charlotte commented a song about police
brutality towards black people in 2020
what are you doing so charlie apparently
responded here
uh oh trisha shares video that claims
charlene dixie said the edward charlie
addressed the clip in her instagram
story she clapped back on you
to reiterate last night dixie danced to
a sound so you saw
me and where did he i did oh i didn't i
didn't see this too
i don't know but i i apologize yeah i
think he i don't think i'm a credible
news source i swear i didn't know
otherwise i would have deleted it for
sure
on tick tock promoting it to your 40 no
one said i'm like cnn over here
come on you can't use that as an excuse
i apologize what else can i do i'm so
sorry i really am where did she where
did she
and then but then delete it
what's the point you're trying to make
you guys are 10 times worse you're doing
it wait
where's the point where she responds
this is just what we watched i
be like yeah i would have deleted it
like embarrassing charlie
charlie addressed the clip on her
instagram story oh here this one
she said if you would like to see the
video of dixie and i dancing with the
actual sound feel free to check it out
wait you responded oh cause i thought
she was talking about this like i swear
i thought she was talking like
she got the n-word i just thought i
would repost the video
if you would like so anyway they're like
we didn't say it i literally thought it
was that video if they thought she
bleeped it out or something i've heard
okay so you so you lost that one you
took the l on that one oh i'll take l's
my whole life i'm the l train
but so tricia tweeted couldn't care less
about charlie and her racist leech of
assist oh
let me open this man we're getting to
the end of this guys
couldn't care less about charlie and a
racist leech of a sister hope they
succeeded dancing or whatever they do
but james he's a piece of [ __ ] his
parents should be ashamed
never apologizes always an excuse he is
always the victim impressive that's
insane
are you impressed so impressed how you
can make everything about you from the
beginning about charlie
he's like you respect his game a little
bit
it sounds like i am i do god i wish like
i
that's amazing that he and he's still so
successful like well okay damn
james responded to i mean this is
getting really long drawn at this point
as a side note james told girl not to
have oh yeah this was the one we were
talking i mean
but the fact that he can't apologize you
can't just say i'm taking accountability
because it wasn't meant to be malicious
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're you said
a race of [ __ ] apologize for it
this i'm kind of unrelated but like the
next day he told this girl don't have
children please because she said
which you know like she said she doesn't
want her boy wearing a her
young son wearing a dress which you know
your whole situation with trish and i
thought oh okay
makes sense he can defend himself but
then for you to turn around and do
something very similar to such a douchey
thing
of you and very obnoxious i've seen you
pop up on my feed millions of times
and um i've never once thought it was
appropriate to harass you
or wish some unkindness upon you for
your lifestyle
it is crazy to me that there are literal
child molesters out there people who
beat and starve their kids and you all
are so pressed
because i say that it's not acceptable
in my house for my son to wear a dress
i'm going to continue to parent the way
i see fit in my household james charles
i mean yeah it's obviously a
conservative uh
viewpoint but it doesn't mean that she's
not a good comment it's a gross comment
sure you don't have children like he's
yeah it's super great dictate the
internet like that's my thing you're
just one okay okay
and racist sit down james like
so how long we've been going dan like 10
hours oh my god this is our longest
episode ever
and finally because i don't want to talk
about this anymore wendy williams goes
after
charlie whoops i don't mean to like it i
don't want to like you're like the pope
right now
yeah i just love it wendy's a [ __ ] i
hate where
i love wendy well actually i wish you
would retire and i'll take your spot
yes i mean who doesn't get backlash
exactly everyone i mean hopefully it
shows you know so she perhaps she should
be a little more grateful but now
you don't think i'm grateful and you
collect those checks
wait what did you say you continue to be
ungrateful and collect those checks yeah
something like that
at all i don't see any tears i don't
feel sorry i mean it was definitely fake
this backlash is warranted yes yes
that's funny i mean that's a gig
i don't i don't think the backlash was
worn okay it's like how i started
calling like making fun of anders wait
that's like his gig that's his thing
like
that's her thing what if she's supposed
to be nice and be like you know what i
feel sorry that's her thing
yours take her so seriously like [ __ ]
so much more [ __ ] here but i like i'm
i'm just don't i'm like i'm kind of over
it karina said imagine talking about 16.
larry said good morning to everyone
patricia larry stop having kobe parties
you dumb
[ __ ] the day after she called out the
emilia trisha
oh liza you talk [ __ ] on liza listen
the demilious james charles you called
on addison ray
tony lopez is sexting miners
you guys so that is predatory behavior
he's sexting
miners yes he said i'm sorry why are
people focusing on this negative thing
that happened
he admitted to it he said i'm sorry he
apologized for it but that in that case
apologies don't make sense
like it's insane there's honestly i
thought we'd be able to do this but
there's so much drama trisha
it's crazy it's literally everybody it
was old news by the time i got here
i knew it it's like whatever we didn't
even have to talk about it it was like
not a big deal
no i wanted to talk about all of it but
okay so here's my here's ethan's final
thoughts
if i can be so bold to give my wise take
i don't know last time you had final
thoughts everyone had something to say
why i had a good final thought last week
they kind of came for you guys
i don't remember what my final thought
was but i'm sure it was really wise
i don't think it was it was i think it
was poorly
here's ethan's final thoughts
charlie is a young girl she seems sweet
too honestly by any uh
metric oh she definitely seems stuck up
so entitled
so spoiled for sure for sure for sure
i mean there's definitely uh excuse me
is this ethan's final thoughts or
trisha's
i believe it's called the front of me
podcast well you have your turn and i'll
have my turn your final thoughts you
sure
love it i actually have no thoughts on
this anymore okay charlie
i think got dog okay you know what i saw
a lot of people making a good point
about this situation
a lot of the young men influencers who
are popular
like bryce hall or whoever the [ __ ] that
is he gets in literal fights with
beats up random people and people get
over that real quick
where charlie acts a little bit stubborn
and stuck up in a video where she spits
out gross food
and all of a sudden people are unsubbing
from her i mean
the poor girl is catching way more [ __ ]
than she deserves
that being said she's a public figure
and this kind of [ __ ] happens as part of
the game it's part of the
it's part of the media churn like she's
the biggest tick-tocker she's a huge
celebrity
and so people like you self-admittedly
want to get in on the action want to get
views right
that's what i do that's what you do and
you're up and you're honest about it
which is good
but um actually i think you were honest
about it i actually have to say
after reviewing everything i think you
were fair and i think the problem came
up
when dixie and james came out the
woodworks with some [ __ ]
sabotaging charlie charlie i feel free
girl you gotta watch these around so
i actually i absolve charlie i don't
think charlie did anything wrong
agree but dixie and james crossed the
line
and then they went to war with with
trisha paytas who
is uh she trisha paytas is like um
how do i think how do i put this she's
like she's like the north vietnamese
oh okay it's like you think you should
be able to beat them
but they just [ __ ] they're gorillas
they hide
they don't play by the rules and you
just and you just get stuck in the
in the rice fields and the bogs in the
jungle and by the time the
the by the time you have so many
casualties and you're so over it you
just want to go home
and nobody wins in the end oh yeah it's
no holds barred you're north
north vietnam was the communist right
dan yeah so you're north vietnam
i'm single the viet cong right so you're
the viet cong
right i'm a single 32 year old infertile
woman i got nothing to lose i'm trapped
you want to give my final thoughts is
this you can come from really well i've
been cancelled people know that i have a
i've been a piece of [ __ ] in the past
and that's fine but i just feel like
like don't come down to my level ever i
think that's the moral of this story
like once you hit down to tricia
peterson's level then you are also
trash gabby hannah damn you know just
all the people you feel that you're like
you're kind of overly insulting yourself
i feel like you're deflecting
i'm very self-aware that i'm hated and
i'm okay with that like i know i'm not a
[ __ ] person
but i know i've done [ __ ] things for
money you know i've definitely trolled
for money yeah i definitely have that
like whatever hitler's like whatever you
know what i mean
yeah we'll be careful i'm trying to
retreat i try to retract the best i can
but you know people people just won't
forgive me and that's
fine i don't expect it i make a ton of
money so it's fine that's like her she's
making money like why are you caring
like i really don't
know because she because she's a young
girl her feelings are her she feels bad
you know her all the time and you just
ask me she's 16 you're an adult
my here's my my thing like suck it up
like people
people like don't tell us okay you have
to no because that's tough skin and this
is this is what i don't like well she'll
get there
gloves handling kids with gloves these
people nowadays is like don't and i kind
of agree like don't bully people at
school but i got bullied so hard that it
gave me the toughest skin ever that when
people say [ __ ] i'm like numb
well that's good i think influencers i
think the longevity
longevity of an inflower influencer has
a lot to do with how they handle
criticism
because i think every influencer that
rises to the top goes through a period
where everybody turns on them
oh yeah and it depends on how they get
through that their longevity it happens
to everybody and it's
very very difficult and it's very very
hard and it's just
awful you feel awful it's exhausting so
i think you know she's being tested for
the first time and it's very difficult
and like but some people do come back
from it i feel like
paul came back but then you have like
shay carl who just like like the hidden
ring i mean everything
pewdiepie went through it crazy shane is
going through it now
and literally everybody everybody's like
i've been through it a lot
and i'm like a phoenix i'm more
beautiful than i ever was no i'm kidding
people hate me they still hate me but
it's okay see now you're being like
deflecting yourself
you're just like oh yeah people hate me
but i don't think they do a lot of
people hate me
a lot of people hate a lot of people
people just like in the world like it's
just working out it's hard but it's
you know it's very difficult for people
to handle people hating you that they've
never met you it's like what the [ __ ]
but you got to grow tough skin if you're
going to be on the internet
we're over it donnie osmond is back in
vegas next year he's doing solo he's
returning without me
why are you promoting donnie osmond does
tickets go on sale today
what are you being paid to promote
donnie husband i go see him every year
on my birthday and this year
i've loved danielle since i was 13.
would you believe would you how old is
he
he's 62 is that your age that would be
super anna nicole smith if you married
him oh he's so hot but he's mormon and
he doesn't believe in [ __ ] he said
his wife has never given him a [ __ ]
on hearthstone because he finds it
disrespectful so maybe he is my ideal
guy disrespectful there's no greater
sign of respect than
this whole world maybe i'll marry donny
osmond who knows
he's mormon i go for the next religion
of mormonism
by jews oh you would totally become a
mormon you're like [ __ ] i found
i'm mormon guys hey i love him jfk
junior is not still alive he is in fact
dead
that was the other thing i wanted to
bring up but we just missed it
completely
wait what the [ __ ] did you say yeah it's
a tic tac thing right now everyone
thinks jfk junior still alive did you
see it
yeah oh for real yeah but he's related
what is jfk junior up to we all think
that this random dude
is secretly jfk junior he didn't die in
a plane crash but he actually went
underground to fight the deep state and
he's helping doctors they love jfk
junior that's what i'm saying oh weird
yeah
that's weird that they love him and
there's this dude who
doesn't look anything like jfk junior
that all these people think is him
in like disguise that he's just cruising
around and opens and he goes all
he goes to all the trump rallies he's
there he's like a little oh he's just
some random nobody
i swear to god dude you gotta love that
he's in on this conspiracy but he goes
to all the trump rallies
like well no he's not playing it cool at
all yeah no he
yeah exactly he's definitely dead yeah
super dead
super dad let him rest in peace like
okay you wouldn't be mega
right yeah one thing i sure about is jfk
junior wouldn't be mega
they're trying to make him into that for
a guy i just let him be man
seriously if i when i die can people let
me recipes they're not going to are they
what do you care if what people say when
you're dead because i do believe in
resting in peace what if i'm like
literally turning in my grave when
people are talking about me like [ __ ]
they're like good she's [ __ ] dead
that [ __ ] i'm sure people are gonna say
that people say that
but that's the life you live you just
you came to terms with it
and this is why i'm converting judaism
so i don't go to hell because they don't
exist in judaism
hell does not exist so i'll be in some
sort of heaven maybe the lower heaven
but at least i'll be in heaven
cool really you're over there
what happened why are you over it i
think because i'm just taking a little
break from my jewish boyfriend's home
so you're over the jew you so you leave
the man you leave the religion
i think so wow is that how it works i
think so yeah
i think that's what it's all about all
right
okay well thanks everybody i hope that
was interesting that was a hell of a
ride for sure
yeah i feel like we didn't get to the
good part you just focus what did i miss
about everything i know but it was like
the aftermath of all of it that came out
but that's okay
what did i miss we talked for two hours
about it i wish we could talk longer
what did i miss tell me the highlight of
my week to be honest what did i miss
well you missed a lot because there's a
lot more notes there oh you mean all
this
[ __ ] talking well this stuff doesn't
matter
it's just i mean you're beefing with
random yeah but it does matter like
nikita dragon not wearing a mask of
[ __ ] saddle range right all right
let's do it you guys ready for another
hour wait wait wait wait i'm in the land
i promise my favorite is dixie
bryce hall all these people thinking are
you gonna have to speak with them did
you hold on hold on
i will do this if you let me blast
through it
no no no no because you make everything
so
you already did twice okay let me let's
just end it it's fine
just hey wear a mask don't have parties
[ __ ]
that's it jfk junior is under a ground
agent stopping uh for the pedophile
right now
i'm not mentioning trisha then she'll go
away like if people stop feeding me
don't you understand that trish is like
rumpelstiltskin
i'm like medusa you bite my head off is
that what you said where should you bite
her head off if she has more heads
coming out of her
yeah medusa turns you to stone you're
the hydra
yeah because when people stop talking
you're the viet cong what's that
i felt like that was a really good
analogy dan don't you
i'm a hydra [ __ ] no you're the viet
cong what's a viet cong
it's the north vietnamese damn you
weren't even listening
nah you wouldn't like it is that where
kim jong-un is
no dude that's north korea i'm friends
with dennis rodman we could go over
together
really i was on his podcast but never
aired
oh that's pretty weird yeah i was giving
relationship advice with dennis robin to
this couple
and they never aired it you must have
bombed well i think
it just got canceled period like they
just never uploaded again i don't think
dennis robin's that interesting or
conversationless
we weren't getting we're doing a
conversation we were giving people
relationship advice we end it
donna's rodman if you want to go to
north kong with me i'm down
whatever you just said okay guys we'll
see you next week thanks for watching
and happy thanksgiving right oh yeah can
i just also acknowledge real quick that
i am not problematic i was going to show
up today in a pilgrimage because i had a
really sexy pilgrim outfit and i did not
wear it because i did not want to be
problematic because this is 20 20 you're
being woke
and not being racist remember turkey are
animals
dixie dixie would totally show up in a
pilgrim outfit
oh my god dixie demilio
yes i was like what are you talking
about why don't we get up and walk away
and i'm just sitting here like an idiot
[Music]
bye
you